ce jeudi 1er octobre a été marquée par
l'inauguration de l'ehpad saint françois
d'assise rénové en 2015 cet
établissement dispose de 77 chambres
individuelles et de deux chambres
doubles sa répartie sur deux niveaux
l'ehpad saint françois d'assise dispose
également d'un espace d'hébergement et
de services spécialisés de 12 places
accueillant des personnes atteintes de
la maladie d'alzheimer
c'est un projet qui remonte à pas mal de
temps sa part donc d'une augmentation de
places conseil départemental nous a
donné pour passer de 120 à 160 places
donc sur cet établissement seulement 80
en partie qui était construite de sa
déjà été livrés et là c'est la partie
qui restait c'était la partie donc de
réhabilitation
ce sont de nouveaux logements et
logement plus adapté plus conforme au
confort moderne et surtout tenant compte
de
commentaire de la personne et chaque
chant est un véritable lieu de vie
différent de chacun des pensionnaires
le conseil départemental a financé cet
établissement à hauteur de 11 millions
d'euros pour l'immobilier
cinq cent trente cinq mille euros pour
le mobilier et a garanti l'emprunt n'est
pas d'offre ainsi à ses résidents un
grand confort dans un espace à vivre
agréable et sécurisant ça a été deux des
jeunes sur la garantie d'emprunt
puisqu'on a garanti emprunts contractés
par l'association saint françois
d'assise et pour un coût de construction
de plus de 11 millions d'euros
donc en parallèle ce coût de
construction sera impacté sur le cours
de journée et le département en charge
tant sur les d'hébergement que sur la
dépendance
la prise en charge pour les personnes
relevant de l'aide sociale il magnitude
est la devise de cet établissement
l'ehpad saint françois d'assise
s'inscrit dans une démarche de
personnalisation de l'accueil et dans
une approche du prendre soin centrée sur
la personne prenant en compte son
histoire de vie ses habitudes et ses
envies ce qu'on essaie de mettre en
place c'est un établissement innovant de
par l'humanitude l'humanitude ça prend
en compte les habitudes de vie des
résidents dans toute son histoire est
derrière on essaie de mettre en place
donc des ateliers des ateliers de
projets de vie ou là justement l'objet 7
et son histoire ses habitudes de vie et
de faire coïncider avec notre
organisation on a des résidents par
exemple tri souhaitent dormir jusqu'à
11h par exemple l'objectif c'est pouvoir
lui apporter le petit déjeuner à 11
heures s'ils le souhaitent
l'humanitude c'est finalement
supprimez les organisations tout en y
intégrant une forme aussi de prise en
charge
c'est quelque chose c'est un aspect
assez innovant de la prise en charge des
personnes âgées dépendantes en
établissement à l'institution beaucoup
d'établissements s'en saisisse mais nous
on essaye quand même de mettre ça en
place depuis plus de cinq ans et c'est
un des projets phares de ceux de cet
établissement du projet d'établissement
l'ehpad saint françois d'assise
idéalement situé dans le quartier du
jardin de l'état offre à ses résidents
confort et sécurité mais aussi un
accueil vivant et rassurant